All right.
Two prominent members of the Oath
Keepers are being sentenced
for their actions
on the attack on the U.S.
Capitol on January six of 2021.
The judge
saying that
the actions of Stewart
Rhodes, the founder
and the leader of the far
right group,
the Oath
Keepers, amounted to domestic terrorism,
that he is going to be sentenced
to 18 years in prison.
Kelly Meggs also being sentenced today.
They were both found guilty,
you may recall, of seditious conspiracy.
We have CNN senior crime and justice
reporter Caitlin Palance joining us now.
Caitlin, this just broke.
Tell us the very latest
Right.
So the judge has just delivered
the sentence to Stewart Rhodes.
He will be spending 18 years
in federal prison
for the crimes
he committed up to
and including on January six
as he gathered those Oath Keepers
to Washington, D.C.
And then they went inside the Capitol.
And when he was leading the organization
and wanting to essentially
foment violence in the United States
because of what the government was doing,
because of the transfer of power
from Donald Trump to Joe Biden,
the judge made
is just finishing his speech to Rhodes
and delivering that sentence right now.
And he is fully aware.
You can tell by what the judge is saying,
how worried he is for the ongoing threat
that this political extreme schism
that Stewart Rhodes espouses.
Even today,
he the judge just asked,
I dare say we now
hold our collective breath
when an election is approaching,
we have another January six.
It remains to be seen.
And then he pointed out to Rhodes
how much Rhodes is not showing
any remorse at all.
And that how he is believing
from what Stewart
Rhodes just said
in the courtroom to him
today,
that Rhodes is ready to take up arms.
The moment
he is released from prison,
that now we know that will be many,
many years from now.
18 years
is what the sentence
is at this time, Brianna.
So the judge, his words here
in terms of making this decision,
quoting here,
this is an additional level
of calculation. Speaking of Rhodes.
This is an additional level of planning.
This is an additional level
of targeting an institution
of American democracy
at its most important moment,
the transfer of power
that informing the judge's
decision here, saying
here was the time when the U.S.
was was when the Congress, the U.S.
Congress was certifying the election.
And that's
when Rhodes and his group,
in the judge's view, struck.
And that's informed the judge's decision
to describe this as,
in effect, domestic terrorism.
Judge made
it also getting to the root
of the
planning and organization
that went into this attack,
saying, quote,
He was the reason they were,
in fact, in Washington,
D.C., Oath Keepers
wouldn't have been there.
But for Stewart Rhodes,
I don't think anyone contends otherwise.
Caitlin if you're still with us,
bring us up to speed
on the situation with his accomplice,
who's also facing a sentence today.
Right.
That man is named Kelly Meggs.
He's from Florida,
and he is
essentially the number two,
the person that Rhodes
was giving direction to
and who was leading others on January
six in Washington, D.C..
Now, the judge has already indicated
that Meggs would not have been
doing those things
if it were not for Rhodes.
And so
there is the possibility
that he could get
a much lighter sentence
or at least a lighter sentence
than Stewart Rhodes.
Today, we know that.
18 years for Stewart Rhodes,
the Justice Department
is asking for more than that.
We know, too, that Kelly Meggs
just wants 21 years for him.
It doesn't look like
he would get that much amount of time,
but we don't know yet
exactly how his sentencing will go.
That is not until one 30 this afternoon.
But Judge Matt really does
have some harsh words
for Stewart
Rhodes today
and how much of a threat
seditious conspiracy
and what these men did,
what the Oath Keepers did on January six.
Did to shake the foundation of democracy
and the transfer of power.
Caitlin,
you've been covering this for some time.
The judge said that
Rhodes did not express remorse for this,
and the judge stated that it feared that
if freed, he'd attempt this again.
What exactly did Rhodes say
through the course of this trial
that gave the judge that concern?
Right.
Well, the judge's words specifically
was that as we heard you speak today,
the moment you are released
you will be prepared
to take up arms against our government.
He's quoting back to him.
And that's because Stewart Rhodes
spoke for about 20 minutes today
and essentially
essentially revealed
how extreme he still is.
He believes
that the election of 2020 was illegal.
that there is a criminal regime
governing the United States
he believes he is a political prisoner.
But budgets matter.
Said to him, no, you are not.
It is not because
of your political beliefs
that you are here today
is because you believe
violence was the way to achieve
the outcome of the election
that you preferred.
And that is not the way that American
democracy works.
There was so much
so much evidence to Katelyn here about
not just what Rhodes did in the lead up
to January 6th and enduring and term
in terms of coordination
but what he did afterwards. Right.
You had some
who were facing charges
who were trying to make an argument
that this was something
that got out of hand.
His actions
right afterwards in the weeks and months
that followed
made it very clear,
no, this was the entire point of
what he was trying to do.
Right.
He was still sending messages
even after January six.
And that became a key
piece of why
this was a seditious conspiracy case.
I mean, they had been waiting
the Oath Keepers and Rhodes were waiting
for President Trump
at the time to basically call them
and invoke the Insurrection
Act to take over the Capitol
and block the transfer of power.
And when they failed on January six,
Rhodes continued
to send messages
to his group,
essentially saying that
maybe they should consider
maybe they should regroup
and continue to figure this out.
So that is really part
of what this case is.
And yesterday,
whenever the Justice Department
was beginning
to lay out some of their arguments,
for this sentencing today,
they were reading back to back
many of the things that Seward Rhodes
were saying
and brought it up again
today, that how often
he talked about fighting,
about bloody revolution, about civil war.
And then after that,
the judge acknowledged today
that there was no documented
message of Stewart
Rhodes ever expressing regret
after January six
in the many, many messages that he said.
We want to get
some legal perspective now.
Caitlin, please stand by.
Let's go to Dave
Arenberg, who's been watching this case
very closely.
Dave, your reaction to this sentence?
18 years for Stewart Rhodes.
The prosecutor's asking for 25
Yeah, I thought it was
a little light there.
Prosecutors asked for something
within the sentencing guidelines,
and the judge,
after hearing Rose's
diatribe, still gave him under
what the prosecutors asked for.
But it's so significant
because you rarely see anyone convicted
for this seditious conspiracy.
And when I heard the words that Stewart
Rhodes said,
it made it clear to me
that he is playing for a pardon.
He knows he's going to be
serving years in prison.
And he thinks his best chance
to get out of prison
is not by showing remorse.
It's not on appeal.
It's by hoping that Donald Trump becomes
president again
and then getting a pardon from him.
Yeah, well,
we should note
during the CNN town hall,
President Trump said
that he would be inclined to pardon
many of the January six writers
who said that in a public forum.
And Perez you've covered
just department a long time.
As you know,
the FBI has said for years that domestic
extremist right wing extremists
are the number one
terror threat in this country,
which I think folks at home
might not be aware of.
You know, in an age
the last decade or two
when Islamist international terrorism
has been such a threat,
the FBI has said explicitly
both under the Biden
and Trump administrations.
This is the biggest terrorism threat.
Right.
And it's a it's a really complex threat
that the FBI, the Homeland
Security Department,
you know,
they grapple with because these groups,
they recruit
from former military members.
They recruit
former police people who are essentially,
you know, trained to protect us, protect
the Constitution,
protect our institutions.
And they adopt this ideology
that essentially
takes the view
that you know, the institutions
need to be brought down,
that the US government is the enemy.
And so this
this is appealed
to a lot of people around the country.
And this
this group, the Oath
Keepers in particular,
you know, are very tricky
for the FBI to deal with
because as you can tell,
you know,
there's a lot of
sympathy for
for some of these guys, depending
on where you are in the country.
And again,
because of the fact
that they have this past in the U.S.
military,
it's often
a very difficult thing
for them
to try to infiltrate these groups,
to try to
figure out where does the threat lie?
Right.
A lot of times,
especially in the last couple of years
with some of the racial justice
protests, these guys would show up
to try to essentially instigate things.
And so that's one of the difficulties
here of the
for the FBI is to try to figure out,
you know, how to go at these groups
without violating
their First Amendment rights.
You have a right, by the way,
to say that the U.S.
government is wrong
and you have a right
to protest all of that.
Where it crosses the line
is, of course, what these
these men are accused of doing,
which is to try to essentially use
that moment on January six to try to
block the transfer of power.